the AI arms race is on and it seems
nothing can slow it down Google says
it's launching its own artificial
intelligence-powered chatbot to rival
chat GPT too much AI too fast it feels
like every week some new AI product is
coming onto the scene and doing things
never remotely thought possible
we're in a really unprecedented period
in the history of artificial
intelligence it's really important to
note that it's unpredictable how capable
these models are as we scale them up and
that's led to a fierce debate about the
safety of this technology
we need a wake-up call here we have a
perfect storm of corporate
irresponsibility widespread adoption of
these new tools a lack of Regulation and
a huge number of unknowns
some researchers are concerned that as
these models get bigger and better they
might one day pose catastrophic risks to
society
so how could ai go wrong and what can we
do to avoid disaster
[Music]
so there's several risks posed by these
large language models
one class of risks is not all that
different from the risk posed by
previous Technologies like the internet
social media for example there's a risk
of misinformation because you could ask
the model to say something that's not
true but in a very sophisticated way and
post it all over social media there's a
risk of bias so they might spew harmful
content about people of certain classes
some researchers are concerned that as
these models get bigger and better they
might one day pose catastrophic risks to
society
for example you might ask a model to
produce something from a factory setting
that it requires a lot of energy for and
in service of that goal of helping you
your factory production it might not
realize that it's bad to hack into
energy systems that are connected to the
internet and because it's super smart it
can get around our security defenses
hacks into all these Energy Systems and
that could cause you know serious
problems
perhaps a a bigger source of concern
might be the fact that bad actors just
misuse these models for example
terrorist organizations might use large
language models to you know hack into
government websites or produce
biochemicals by using the models to kind
of discover design new drugs
you might think most of the catastrophic
risks we've discussed are a bit
unrealistic and for the most part that's
probably true but one way we could get
into a very strange world is if the next
generation of big models learned how to
self-improve one way this could happen
is if we told uh you know a really
Advanced machine learning model to
develop uh you know an even better more
efficient machine learning model
if that were to occur you might get into
some kind of loop where models continue
to get more efficient and better and
then that could lead to even more
unpredictable consequences
[Music]
there are several techniques that Labs
use to you know make their models safer
the most notable is called reinforcement
learning from Human feedback or rhfs the
way this works is labelers are asked to
prompt models with various questions and
if the output is unsafe they tell the
model and the model is then updated so
that it won't do something bad like that
in the future
another technique is called red teaming
throwing the model into a bunch of tests
and then seeing if you can find
weaknesses in it
these types of techniques have worked
reasonably well so far but in the future
it's not guaranteed these techniques
will always work
some researchers worry that models may
eventually recognize that they're being
red teamed and they of course want to
produce output that satisfies their
prompts so they will do so but then once
they're in a different environment they
could behave unpredictably
so there is a role for society to play
here one proposal is to have some kind
of Standards body that sets you know
kind of tests that the various Labs need
to pass before they receive some kind of
certification that hey this lab is safe
another priority for governments is to
invest a lot more money into research on
how to understand these models under the
hood and make them even safer
you can imagine a body like a you know a
CERN that that lives currently in Geneva
Switzerland for physics research
something like that being created for AI
Safety Research so we can try to
understand them better
for all these risks artificial
intelligence also comes with tremendous
promise any task that requires a lot of
intelligence could potentially be helped
by these types of models for example
developing new drugs personalized
education or even coming up with new
types of climate change technology so
the possibilities here truly are endless
so if you'd like to read more about the
risks of artificial intelligence and how
to think about them
please click the link and don't forget
to subscribe